aber man muss schon sagen diese sounds
also wenn ich in chicken mcnuggets
reinweiße auch wenn ich die echte seiten
also mach das nicht dieses geräusch
[Musik]
leute was geht ab und es willkommen bei
einem neuen video leute das ist jetzt
der zweite anlauf ich war noch nie so
schlecht drauf wie eben ich habe das
ganze video aufgenommen ich habe extra
eine pizza bestellt die jetzt noch ja
halb dasteht angebissen und zwar
bestimmt das video einmal darauf dass es
mein bildschirm aufgenommen habe und ich
brauchte wirklich guten sound hat mein
eigenes micro genommen dieses micro es
jetzt neu das hatte ich eben noch gar
nicht habe alles schön aufgenommen mit
wunderbarem sound eigentlich dann will
ich das video schneiden erstes problem
mikrofon war aus batterie weil er von
dem scheiß ding hier normalerweise
täglich das vorher immer außer dieses
mal ja kein delays zweites problem der
bildschirm hat irgendwie ab der hälfte
nicht mehr aufgenommen hatte ich noch
nie in meinem ganzen leben aber jetzt
kommt halt irgendwie alles zusammen so
leute jetzt bin ich trotzdem wieder
einigermaßen gut gelaunt ich musste erst
mal eine stunde aussetzen herbst
wahrscheinlich an diese schon gelesen es
geht heute um das jetzt noch mal asm
ergonomisch genau es geht heute um als
mr
windeln und sirius autonomes sensory
response irgendwas armen café genau und
zwar habe ich vor ungefähr einer woche
das video von marcel scorpion gesehen wo
er sich als mr videos angeschaut hat ich
habe das ganze vor ich habe davon
wirklich noch nicht mitbekommen und das
hat wirklich an amerika einen richtig
großen hype da gibt es videos da essen
leute burger oder so film das film die
geräusche davon und werden dadurch
richtig bekannt dass ist ihren job zu
essen und dann sollt aufzunehmen und
andere leute finden es irgendwie geil so
habe ich zumindest gedacht
[Musik]
ich hatte das ganze wirklich sehr
interessiert und ich habe mich gestern
einen längeren zeitraum damit
beschäftigt und habe mir gedacht das
willst du auch mal ausprobieren wir
machen heute im test
ich will das ganze nicht unbedingt auf
die schippe nehmen ich will dass ernst
behandelt und ich würde es auch wirklich
ausprobiert jetzt komme ich erst mal zum
punkt und versucht das ganze hier
nochmal mit der bildschirm aufnahme von
zwar geht es hier um videos wie zum
beispiel dieses hier von hand rica xml
mcdonald s chicken mcnuggets die teams
also die ist da wirklich 20 chicken
mcnuggets das video geht 16 minuten und
26 millionen leute finden das irgendwie
erotisch oder entspannt das anzuschauen
das klingt total krank habe ich am
anfang auch gedacht aber wenn man sich
jetzt hier mal die definition durchliest
autonomes sensory meridian response
blablabla bezeichnet die erfahrung eines
statisch ähnlichen oder kribbeln gefühls
auf der haut das typischerweise auf der
kopfhaut beginnt und sich am nacken und
der oberen wirbelsäule entlang bewegt so
ich habe mir diese videos angeschaut und
habe das dann halt auch gestern schon
mal gegoogelt und kann das absolut nicht
nachvollziehen ich bin mir sicher einige
von euch haben keine ahnung um was ist
hier überhaupt geht deswegen würde ich
sagen wir schauen einfach mal kurz rein
so ich bin euch gestern auf dieses video
gestoßen
dieses mikrofon nervt mich gerade total
aber lasst euch davon nicht irritieren
das brauchen wir gleich noch und zwar
wenn man die jetzt mal als mr
asm erfurt ein gibt zum beispiel gibt es
unzählige videos wo leute halt schicken
essen dass hier was auch immer das sein
soll
burger king sushi shrimps casey obst
also wirklich alles mögliche und mit
einem guten mikrofon wie ich das auch
hier gerade von jugend bekümmert danke
übrigens an dieser stelle wirklich sehr
nett uns welche ist aufgeschlossen
gewesen ja aufnehmen in deutschland gibt
es auch schon irgend so eine die ich
gefunden habe die das macht und ich habe
mir gestern abend überlegt dieses video
zu machen weil ich mich wirklich eine
zeit lang mit beschäftigt hat und das
wirklich natürlich ist es sehr komisch
habe ich ja schon gesagt aber es ist
auch interessant und wir schauen uns
jetzt erstmal hier das mcdonald's video
an weil das glaube ich eigentlich am
besten das widerspiegelt und was es geht
[Gelächter]
hier wurde oder nämlich erotisch das
sollte man nur die augen schließt und
sich auf die töne einlässt ein
entspannendes gefühl weil die auf der
kopfhaut verursachen was über den nacken
und die wirbelsäule zu spiel spielen
spüren ist das will ich ja ausprobieren
und eben habe ich natürlich schon einmal
aufgenommen da ist nichts passiert das
habe ich auch im video gesagt aber das
video ist ja vielleicht deswegen dem was
jetzt noch mal nen euro nicht es ist
auch noch mal neu und ich mache noch
lauter
es ist brutal ich also ich finde es auch
täglich wobei jetzt auch wir hatten es
auch recht laut
aber ganz wichtig ist auch sie flüstert
dabei passt auf das machen wir jetzt
hier gleich mal
und jetzt haut die da ihre zwölf soße
auf dem tisch und futtert hat einfach
die ganzen kinder gibt es einen nach dem
anderen das geht 16 minuten und trinkt
dabei ab und zu was von der cola oder
von diesem milchshake und das ist halt
das video aber man muss schon sagen
diese sounds also wenn ich in chicken
mcnuggets reinweiße auch wenn ich die
rechte seite macht das nicht dieses
geräusch ergänze hat als das ist
irgendwie so ein gefühl bei mir auslöst
wir gehen wir hier zum schluss da also
hier an dieser stelle das habe ich eben
auch schon gesagt bei mir löst das
absolut kein gefühl auch so wie es hier
steht ja wir haben hier dieses gefühl
wird als beruhigen und angenehm
empfunden und häufig durch akustische
visuelle und taktile sinnesreize
sogenannte trigger ausgelöst
beispielsweise durch leichte berührung
am kopf bestimmte geräusche zum beispiel
das treiben von händen und lippen
geräuschen und so weiter also das ist
diese definition dahinter jetzt grob
gefasst aber die ganzen youtube-videos
beziehung natürlich auch diese auditive
ebenso ich habe jetzt pizza bestellt die
sich jetzt leider nur noch so aus
einfach weil ich das eben schon getestet
habe ich habe ja schon gesagt das hat
nicht funktioniert
dazu noch diesen gekühlten apfelsaft der
leider nicht mehr so gekühlt ist und
pizzabrötchen die die aber noch relativ
ganz sind und ja hier ist dieses fette
mikrofon das ist wirklich ein sehr sehr
gutes mikrofon kostet glaube ich mehrere
hundert euro und das verstärkt natürlich
den sound dahinter und ja ich würde
sagen wir machen den live test ich würde
nämlich sehr gerne von euch wissen wie
eure reaktion darauf ist wenn ich jetzt
hier pizza ist und man diese sounds
davon wirklich casino er spürt keine
ahnung wir können ja gerne alle
kopfhörer rein machen oder so ich will
mich jetzt gar nicht darüber lustig
machen ich will das wirklich ernst
nehmen auch wenn es sich ein bisschen
krank anhalt das ist ganz klar wenn ihr
darauf keinen bock hat dann schaltet
jetzt einfach
aber wir machen das jetzt einfach mal
ich suche jetzt auch mal dran so wie das
im video gemacht haben dass man mich
jetzt nicht ganz sieht das ist ganz ganz
wichtig da stellen wir das ganze noch
das geld ist und ihr schreibt dass ein
altes stück
nicht sehr lecker so das fällt jetzt
auch danke für ihr durchhaltevermögen so
leute das war jetzt mein video wie
gesagt also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
bei mir löst das ganze nicht das aus was
der sinn dahinter ist schreibt gerne in
die kommentare wie es bei euch war
natürlich war das video ein bisschen
verstört das gebe ich auch ganz offen
und ehrlich zu aber es hat mich gestern
einfach so interessiert deswegen habe
ich dieses video gemacht
er lasse gerne da nach oben da wenn es
euch trotzdem unterhalten hat und wir
sehen uns übermorgen wieder auf wie ein
normales video hat rein